There was once a merchant who had bad luck.
He lost all his money and everything he owned.
One day, he came to a big house.
A servant walked up to the dogs and put down four bowls of food on the floor for them.
The bowls were made of gold.
He watched the dogs eat.
One of them looked up at him.
He pushed the bowl towards the poor merchant.
"The dog wants me to eat," the merchant thought.
When he finished eating, he thought, "I'll take this bowl and sell it."
He sold the bowl made of gold and bought a shop.
Many years passed.
Although he was rich, the merchant was not happy.
"I stole the bowl made of gold," he thought.
"I shall not be happy until I repay the owner."
He bought a valuable present and set out for the rich man's house.
To his surprise, it was now in ruins.
He went up to a beggar who was sitting in the ruins.
"Tell me," he said,...
..."what happened here?"
"Where is the great man who used to live here?"
"I am that man," he said.
"This is very sad," the merchant said.
"But now, your luck will change."
"Many years ago, I was very poor."
"One of your dogs pushed his bowl made of gold towards me."
"I stole that bowl and sold it."
"With the money, I bought a shop."
"I filled it with goods and now, I am a rich man."
The beggar waved him away.
"I cannot take the money or the present," he said.
"My dog wanted to give you that bowl."
"I did nothing for you and the dog is long dead."
"Go in peace, friend."
The merchant thought for a while.
Then, he said, "You may be a beggar, but you are truly a rich man."